Ashraf and we have to interrupt you
there because the fathers of the two
victims are speaking uh first Barnaby's
father let's listen in comprehend how
I'm going to do and deal with it myself
and Emma and Charlene
this family and friends
um
well I know Martin would be super
touched by everyone that's here
and he he loved it he loved it here he
couldn't wait to come back drove me mad
but
laughs
his heart will be with you guys forever
and thank you so much I really can't
talk much more so I'm gonna pass it over
thank you
um everyone here
really really want to thank you for your
support
for taking the time to be here
all of you guys everywhere that I see
seeing people
um such a lovely sign
of the University
and the Bold you have
um Grace was
also like Barney she she loves coming up
to Nottingham in fact we couldn't get
her down
I said to her last week come down and
she said well
after she's had a few more sessions you
know I used to call them her crisis
meetings
but
you know
the love that we have out here I just
wish we had it everywhere
so
look after each other
it's the big thing
is that
look after your friends
and look after people around you
this is so important
I think Grace and her friend they fell
together
and
you just you just you need to be friends
with everyone and you need to love
everyone
and I wish we had more of it but most of
all
all of you guys everyone who's here who
grades may not have even touched
I really thank you for being here and
taking the time I really do it means so
much dictionary my wife and me
um she loved me and she loved all of you
she really did and you should all feel
very blessed
and she was so full of her stories and
things that she said about all of you
and you all touched her life and hence
ours
you'd never be forgotten
by us certainly
we we we have children who were taken
away prematurely from us that should
never happen to any parent
but all I can say to all of you guys
is a thank you for things you did for
our daughter and Barney
and
look off and look out for each other
thank you
foreign